hi there Steve Kaufman here today I'm
going to talk about the importance of
context in language learning and I
haven't as is usually the case usually
the case with these I don't have the
written out in advance so my thoughts
are gonna be a little bit disjointed
bear with me here but in language
learning yeah let's start with what sort
of triggered this thought of my mind I
met this morning with a family again
Chinese immigrants father and mother and
their daughter they've been here for 12
years the daughter speaks fluent English
of course has been here since the age of
four she's 16 and both parents struggle
with their English and the the mother
there said yes you know I find it very
difficult when I go to study a list of
words I can't seem to remember them and
it's very frustrating she's been in a
drought years she really can't speak
English very well at all and I thought
to myself well I can't learn from a list
of words because a list of words has no
meaning for me it has no resonance
resonance there's nothing there for me
to grab on to both the parents have
lived here for 12 years don't speak
English very well obviously English is
not very important to them so that
that's another context that's not there
they don't have a strong sense of
wanting to participate in an
english-speaking society so that that
there isn't that context of wanting to
participate in the language but context
goes beyond that it goes you have in my
experience if I learn from you know some
content has resonance for me it's
interesting to me when I'm listening to
some of my Czech material about the
history of Czechoslovakia or whatever it
might be that's of interest to me other
people are interested in other things it
might be music it might be whatever but
but whatever you're learning from has to
be relevant has to be meaningful has to
have resonance it has to have
credibility this is another problem very
often if we're learning from the typical
sort of beginner texts we're not
entirely sure that that's how people
speak at least I'm not I'm not entirely
sure that this is authentic and credible
because in fact it's scripted for me so
you know and I know that some of the
words that they're teaching are not very
important you know most beginner texts
have you going through customs I wonder
how you know how many people have ever
used the language they're learning while
going through customs I know I haven't
so that you start to question the
relevance of this context it's low
resonance obviously reading a list of
words has very little resonance
resonance I think it's so important that
we get engaged you know emotionally with
with the language and the context that
we're learning from and that context is
not only the subject matter that we
might be reading or listening to it's
also the people we associate with it's
our desire to be part of that community
that gives resonance that create a
meaningful context makes it real
credible authentic so yeah I think one
of the difficulties very often that
immigrants from Asia have is that they
seem to be less willing to inject
themselves into the local scene so
therefore English becomes real less
relevant to them it's it's it's not a
meaningful context for them so I don't
know if this makes sense but I think
it's extremely important because you
know the brain is not just some kind of
a machine that you throw them some stuff
in and turn up a handle and outcomes
language ability it's not just the
so-called left side of your brain which
is good at you know dealing with
rational explanations or whatever I
think that there's ample evidence that
it's the whole of the brain that gets
involved and that emotion is a big part
of it and if the learning environment or
the living environment or the
learning materials are not if a context
in which we are learning in every sense
of the word if that context context is
not rich is not authentic credible
vibrant that doesn't grab us then we'll
have a lot tougher time learning so
that's really all I wanted to say I
don't know what we can do about it other
than trying to find or create meaningful
context in other words learning from
material that we like and find
interesting where the voice has a
resonance where the subject matter has
residents a resonance I can still
remember a text that I listened to an
Italian you know promesa Sposi or Anna
Karenina and Russian or some of the
material I'm listening to now in Czech
and and and so that that creates an
attachment and that's gonna help you
learn so and also I think in terms of
interacting with the language as you
know my preference is to wait until
until I have enough of a vocabulary that
I can actually have a meaningful again
interaction one that's authentic and
real and we're actually communicating
meaning so that I'm driven by the desire
to communicate my meaning and understand
the meaning of the other person
I'm not displaying my ability to use the
subjunctive or worrying about whether I
say everything correctly or not because
I've got a meaningful context and it's
meaningful because I have enough of a
vocabulary that I can actually have a
meaningful conversation and have a
chance of understanding what the other
person is saying so that makes that
whole context meaningful so you know do
with this idea what you want but I think
those people who are able to create
meaningful rich authentic credible
learning contexts are generally more
successful language learning language
learners so I look forward to your
comments thank you for this thing bye
for now